y at il un bonjour quelle est la
situation alors sur place et que se
passe-t-il autour de vous alors en ce
moment se tient une conférence de presse
un des des syndicats de police
l'unsa synergie s et ip et l'alliance
évidemment qui a organisé ce grand
défilé et sont au rendez-vous en train
de parler alors en fait à 10h ce matin
ils se sont rendus sur les champs
elysées l'action est évidemment secrète
1 pour que tout se déroule sans
encombres comme vous l'avez dit il
réagissait aux propos de christophe
castaner tenue lundi
il conteste toutes les mesures que
souhaitait mettre en place le ministre
est donc pour manifester
cette colère est le rôle de la police
mettra en lumière le rôle de la police
ils ont d'abord tourné avec des
camionnettes autour de l'arc de triomphe
avec des camionnettes qui étaient
placardés de photos de blessure de
blessure évidemment reçu par des
policiers puis divers slogans ensuite
ils les ont brandi des drapeaux et sont
descendus le long de des champs elysées
donc avec des motos avec des voitures
des camionnettes ou à pied donc en
portant une bannière qui montre et le
slogan pas de police pas de paie donc
aujourd'hui évidemment les policiers
sont très en colère ils demandent qu'on
les laisse travailler avec leur méthode
celle qu'ils ont toujours eu jusqu'à
présent je vous propose d'écouter denis
urt d'unsa police
la police a un petit peu marre d'être
montrés du doigt nous ce qu'on veut tout
simplement c'est faire notre travail
fait respecter les lois et les
règlements le reste c'est de la
politique
nous on veut tout simplement des moyens
pour travailler une bonne formation et
qu' on ne nous enlève pas des techniques
comme ça du jour au lendemain sans les
remplacer le contrôle de tête n'est pas
une erreur moi j'ai été formateur de
nombreuses années ça a fonctionné
c'est un moyen coercitif qui est avant
l'usagé des forces l'intermédiaire des
armes à des renaudières donc si on n'a
pas la coercition ou parce que tu te aux
armes de force intermédiaire et c'est
pas la solution non plus le tazer c'est
une arme comme une autre c'est une arme
ressources intermédiaires
qu'ils aient subi un cadre législatif et
juridique il faut simplement respecter
chez nous tout est dangereux
aucune situation n'est facile à gérer on
ne sait jamais à quelle cette situation
va être confronté donc voilà le métier
de policier difficile tout simplement
donc après avoir également bondi des
fumigènes les policiers sont arrivés
près de la place beauvau et là nous y
sommes donc pour cette conférence de
presse ils ont envie de marquer les
esprits de faire pression sur le
ministre pour qu'il change de ton et
qu'il montre qu'il soutient la
profession qu'ils ont terminée par une
minute de silence
et puis le chant de la marseillaise
voilà pour la situation ici place
beauvau merci beaucoup katia pegg et
nick pour toutes ces précisions en
direct donc de la place beauvau à paris